can you stand down I just needed to get
your attention you're hard man to find
you ever consider a website maybe a
spotlight in this guy a big silhouette
of an arrow what do you want
[Music]
Showtime
what's up see you got my message that
light was perfect me what made you think
of that no I think I saw it in a comic
book somewhere hey everybody this is
gonna be my arrow episode 10 video there
were all kinds of Batman Easter eggs
that wasn't even the end of it there was
another brave in the bold one too that
you guys may have spotted that I'll talk
about but they also gave a big shout out
to the Huntress so a lot of people are
taking that to mean that she might be
coming back this season or maybe even
next season even though they haven't
officially renewed it for season 7
everybody's been saying yeah we're
pretty confident that we're gonna get a
season 7 but I'll address that at the
end of the video and there is a new
round of the flash ring giveaway or
Legion ring if you guys want that all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a comment about the
episode on the video so starting with
the Batman Easter eggs first
you may recognize that actor that was
playing Helena Bertinelli as cousin as
the person from Stargate he's just a
longtime Vancouver actor so he pops up
on a lot of Vancouver based shows
Stargate all the versions of Stargate
were vancouver-based so naturally it's
only a matter of time until all those
Stargate people wind up showing up on
arrow or the DC TV shows and if you are
a big Star Gate fan most of the crew
members that we're working behind the
camera on those Stargate TV shows are
now working on the DC TV shows in
various capacities
the other big Batman Easter Egg aside
from the bat-signal was the sonic kiss
the Black Canary gave two Bertinelli
that's actually from The Brave and the
bold animated TV series it was a black
canary Batman team-up
[Music]
it's sort of a way for her to take
someone down without making their head
explode like a watermelon because her
sonic cry is so powerful it's the same
thing with Black Canary Black Sarah and
Black Canary
I would say about even power levels
Felicity had all kinds of movie
references Diggle is the Six Million
Dollar Man right now they're actually
making a new movie but it's Mark
Wahlberg and it's called the six billion
dollar man turns out six million dollars
does not buy you as much as it used to
but the whole point is is that diggle's
back in the field turns out we're not as
undermanned as we thought we were so you
have old team arrow and new team arrow
so if it wasn't clear the whole idea is
that Kate and James is the person who
leaked the audio of wild dog to the FBI
so that they could compel him to testify
against Oliver which was all intended to
break the team apart so Kate and James
engineered this scenario whereby team
arrow would break up and it'd be easier
to pull a fast one on them they sort of
realized this at the end of the episode
which is why they tried to bring the
team back together but the noobs aren't
having it so obviously there's going to
be this arc in the back half of the
season with two different teams but
Stephen Amell tweeted this after the
episode like good luck noobs like
they're definitely gonna get their asses
handed to them and the whole idea is is
that they have to work together so
obviously in the very classic superhero
way they will not be able to defeat Kate
and James until everybody comes back
together which probably won't happen
until after episode fifteen sixteen
seventeen we'll see usually it's like
the last big arc of the season then
obviously Thea is back Oliver said no
matter what you're doing you'll always
be my speedy meaning that when Roy comes
back he's probably not gonna wear the
costume they actually tweeted this
picture from behind the scenes I believe
that Roy is coming back in episode 15 he
might be back for two episodes so it'll
be a couple weeks before we see them and
there been a lot of theories that he
might be the son the Kate and James lost
during the undertaking like he says he
lost his son so he might be dead he
might be alive out there somewhere we
don't know but it's his whole reason for
seeking revenge against Oliver so it's a
pretty big plot point so because he
feels like Oliver is responsible for the
loss of his son he's gonna start taking
it out on all of her son William who we
actually just saw a bunch
scenes in a trailer running around with
Oliver with blood all over his face so
I'll play that trailer in a second but
there a couple other big easter eggs
like Felicity and Diggle playing Halo
with the T spheres the really long
continuous shot of Oliver taking down
all those villains gauntlet style in the
big warehouse scene was pretty badass
there was a racial girl named drop
Felicity jokes about Oliver having sex
with Huntress remember the last time you
climbed into bed with a Bertinelli that
ended pretty badly she wasn't lying
either Bull Durham one of the best
baseball movies of all time sometimes
you win sometimes you lose
sometimes it rain probably the other
biggest teaser at the end was when Thea
said if Merlyn can change then maybe
black siren can change too
so it's them setting up the idea that
there might actually be a black siren
Redemption arc don't know if she'd ever
turned good but maybe we head into
season seven with her being more of an
antihero we'll see but here's that
trailer for the rest of the season
vigilante put the fear of God in these
guys this is for you so that you'll
suffer these are innocent people and you
can save Queen is under indictment
his team is fractured in a million
pieces
and this city its prime for a takeover
[Music]
okay
you've taught yourself some new tricks
no more games
oh you probably should not have been
allowed to watch that
James is killing dozens of people by
tonight and honors
your team walked into a trap what are
you doing I'm saving the city
shudders up nothing's happening can't be
undone this ends tonight I will never
let you cross that line
[Music]
era so obviously things are gonna get
way crazier between both of the team
arrows and team evil as they fight
together
Quentin's gonna try and redeem black
siren the season is all about family
forgiveness Redemption so we'll see how
they pay that off but the other big
takeaway is that there's going to be
plenty of William adventures with Oliver
as the green arrow like you see them
here in the arrow cave so I'm actually
really excited about that stuff too but
let me know in the comments if there
were any big Easter eggs from the
episode that I didn't mention during the
video and let me know what your most
hyped up about for the rest of the
season but if you didn't see they just
confirmed that wally west will be going
to legends up tomorrow they gave a bunch
of details so i'll do a video about that
next i'll name the giveaway winner when
i post that so click here for brand new
flash and click here for brand new
titans thank you so much for watching
i'll see you guys tonight